guess who was nominated for a nobel
peace prize again
true their dime a dozen trinkets so
useless they threw one at obama just for
brushing his teeth
but it's trump's third and it's for
something new yet again
australian law professors they have them
there nominated him for the trump
doctrine a mix of common sense and
national interest keeping us
from quote endless wars and therefore
killing thousands of young americans
it is funny to be nominated three times
not for making liberals feel good
but for real stuff middle east peace
reducing our military footprint while
expanding our capabilities
beating isis confusing pacifists and
generals alike
it reveals that contrast between most
leaders and trump it's the eloquent
statesman who sends kids to die versus
the obnoxious ruffian who keeps your
kids at home
no one denies trump's personality he'll
never win
a prize for his mostly peaceful press
conferences
but that argument is four years old
which is why the people still crying
about it
seem like they're four years old still
we know joe can handle a room he could
shake hands smile those bright white
teeth
his hair plugs blowing in the breeze he
can talk wistfully about those who
sacrificed their lives
and give you the bad news from his
basement bedroom then go back into
hiding
we won't lose a sleep over biden's
tweets but some of us might lose sleep
over worse things
if you know he'd send in the army again
and again it's worth asking the
candidates tonight
what's a bigger worry mean tweets or a
wasteful
never-ending war trump produced the
tweets
biden supported the war we know the
media's answer to that
but what's yours all right
dana he's got he got three nominations
for three separate reasons two piece
deals the trump doctrine
could he be the greatest president in
the history of the universe
could be could be we will see history
will tell history hotel
um you know i don't think tonight in the
in the buckets of topics uh foreign
policy
won't come up but i bet joe biden maybe
will try to possibly bring up climate
change and try to make that one but one
of these debates will focus on foreign
policy and remember what secretary gates
said
he believed that joe biden had been
wrong on every single
foreign policy issue for the last 30
years um
you know he wrote it in his book like
that it is there and i do think that the
contrast
is quite stark um so i look forward to
the opportunity for them to actually
have that discussion because i think
president trump
has some very good accomplishments that
he can take off that's a good point you
know brett uh if you go
if you remember biden didn't want to
take out osama bin laden and trump took
out salamani took out
isis took out that other dude [ __ ] daddy
bag daddy
so it's yeah i forget that guy's name
he's dead
uh listen he's got a president trump has
a foreign policy record as dana said to
run on
it's not going to be in this debate it
doesn't seem unless one of the
candidates brings it up
and then it's a follow-up but it's not
in the buckets that chris
is focused on uh but he has a tale to
tell
and it's actually tough i think for the
biden folks to say
and look at what happened with israel
and uae and bahrain and say
that's not a good thing in fact biden
put out a statement saying it was
yeah juan are you now going to admit
that you were wrong about trump he's got
three
nobel peace prizes you don't have any
no i'm working on it but i'm working on
it wait a minute he doesn't have three
he has three nominations
i said nominations oh i thought you said
he had three nobel prizes anyway
anybody can be nominated i mean the
difference here is
obama was nominated and won it that's
that's the big deal
but even he wanted it that was desperate
that's what i was going to say and even
obama
didn't make a big deal out of he's
pretty humble about it he didn't go
out campaigning and advertising i was
nominated the media does that for him
pretty weak to me
right i mean he did it for him
oh no i think if you won i think i'd do
it for you oh
well i appreciate it i'm gonna nominate
greg next week i do a lot of good
welcome but i'm saying boy that that
looks weak you know the guy
says he's nominated anybody can be
nominated well you know what it's nice
to be thought of as
bringing peace to the world right jesse
it's true i mean the president i think
when before he was president was
nominated for eight
emmy awards and he got zero so hopefully
he does a little bit better with the
nobel peace prizes
but if you're an intellectually honest
liberal
i know that's a little bit of an
oxymoron but if you are you have to
admit that trump's foreign policy has
been successful do you know the north
koreans have not tested a nuclear device
or an icbm in three years i mean we have
space force
we have peace deals isis annihilated the
two top terrorists taken out
china has been ostracized the iranians
are isolated
i mean this is really good stuff susan
rice is out there complaining about oh
our allies our allies who
who's she talking about the brits the
indians the south koreans the japanese
the israelis
it seems like we have a very nice
alliance system and
president trump despite being called
this big renegade that's going to
create a nuclear holocaust has done the
exact opposite
all right we got to go foreign policy
probably isn't going to come but
china will whether it's hunter biden or
president trump talking about china
that's going to come up tonight you know
we're going to go guys i know you gotta
go i was just gonna say goodbye to you
goodbye brett be safe we'll look forward
to seeing you later
prepare well my friend